there's one thing that stuns me in the
world we're in today
that i do not understand which is what
has always
stood in politics is that when things
happen during
a president's term and you saw this
firsthand that president is accountable
it's just it's on your watch so you're
accountable
and good things happen great you
you benefit some bad things happen you
take the hit
that is the way it has always been in
american politics and now we're in this
strange moment where i watch these ads
these ads for trump and i watch people
campaigning for trump and
and they're running as if he's an
outsider
who's trying to replace president biden
and and so all that and it's and to the
degree that it's almost comical they'll
say
uh elect trump and we'll stop
all of this negativity and this violence
and we'll stop
you know this this the horrors of the
pandemic and we'll stop
all if you don't you hate what's been
happening the last couple of years
what's all going to end
if we could give trump a chance and i
think what what are you talking about
he's the incumbent this is insanity
well this is madness it makes me think
of you know that the tagline when my
husband was president was
thanks obama right right i mean you
remember that
anything anything that happened wrong in
the world
it was thanks obama you know right my
dog died
thanks obama you know
i mean so do you ever use that on him
around the house
oh no we do all the time he left the
mayonnaise
out all night and you're like thanks
that's so perfect